400 يوم على الحرب في اوكرانيا في كل يوم
منها يزداد التصعيد على جميع الصعود من
تصريحات سياسيه وتهديدات الا ان اشدها
وضوحا هي ازدياد تدفق الاسلحه على
الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني اخر الاسلحه
الذكيه التي اعلنت اوكرانيا عن استخدامها
هي ذخائر الهجوم المباشر المشترك والتي
تعرف بجذم والتي تحول القنابل العاديه الى
تلك الموجهه لاصابه الاهداف بدقه اكبر
نجحت طائرتنا بواسطتها في ضرب اهداف مهمه
انها قنابل اقل تاثيرا قليلا ولكنها دقيقه
للغايه
جاءت ضمن حزمه المساعدات الامريكيه لكييف
لتطالب بالمزيد منها خاصه بعد تصريحات
مسؤولين امريكيين عن امكانيه الاعلان عن
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده بقيمه مليارين
و600 مليون دولار تتضمن ذخائر جويه دقيقه
حرب التسليح على الجانب الروسي تستمر ايضا
لتعلن موسكو عن زياده انتاج جميع انواع
الاسلحه العاديه وعاليه الدقه وفق وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه
تم تحديد حجم امدادات الذخيره الاكثر
احتياجا ويجري اتخاذ التدابير اللازمه
لزيادتها وبسبب التوسع في القدرات
الانتاجيه وزياده انتاجيه العمل ازداد
انتاج المصانع الدفاعيه للاسلحه التقليديه
والاسلحه عاليه الدقه لدعم القوه باعداد
مضاعفه
مؤشرات حرب عالميه ثالثه تؤكدها كييف
بمطالبها برفع ضخ السلاح وموسكو بعقيدتها
الجديده والتي في كل بند منها تؤكد على
نيتها ليس في الانتصار فحسب بل في قلب
الادوار وكسر شوكه واشنطن اذا عمر العربيه